monsieur le président
bonne nouvelle
les taux d'intérêt remontent voilà
comment jean marc daniel écrivait
aujourd'hui économistes à billets dans
un journal économique c'était vrai qu'en
théorie ce serait une bonne nouvelle
mais ce n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
pour la france ce n'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour la france eu égard à
l'état de nos finances publiques
voilà depuis dix ans depuis dix ans que
le déficit ne cesse d'augmenter quelle
que soit la croissance mauvaises comme
exceptionnel mauvaises comme
exceptionnel et depuis dix ans l'écart
se creuse comme le souligne la cour des
comptes entre la france et l'allemagne
là où il y avait quatre points d'écart
de dette il y en a 40 dix ans après
alors monsieur le bis de l'économie qui
n'est pas là mais je remercie l idée du
soft de le suppléer
est ce que vous êtes aussi alarmé par
les finances publiques que la cour des
comptes pour vous répondre la parole et
communistes délégué chargé des comptes
publics
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur d'achères nous interroger sur
la situation des finances publiques est
peut-être plus précisément encore sur la
trajectoire des finances publiques dans
les années qui viennent les chiffres
dont nous disposons aujourd'hui sont des
chiffres assurant surtout à la sortie
d'une crise telle que celle que nous
avons connue pourquoi rassurant
j'entends un j'entends les quolibets
j'entends les rires toujours les mêmes
aux oiseaux de mauvaise augure qui
préfèrent les mauvaises nouvelles aux
bonnes moi j'insiste sur les bonnes
nouvelles les bonnes nouvelles c'est une
croissance à 7% les bonnes nouvelles ces
tonneaux un taux d'emploi que nous
n'avons jamais atteint depuis 1969 les
bonnes nouvelles ces 650 mille créations
d'emplois dans le secteur privé et les
bonnes nouvelles c'est un investissement
qui repart à la hausse cette croissance
est inattendu et c'est une bonne
nouvelle parce que cette croissance nous
permet de réduire les déficits publics
public plus rapidement que prévu il sera
inférieur à 7% en 2021 là où nous
craignons 8,2 pour cent et la dette que
tout le monde craignait à 120% sera son
13,6 pour cent face à cette situation
quelle est notre stratégie nos
stratégies c'est le redressement des
comptes publics la croissance la
croissance permet d'avoir des recettes
et ses recettes diminuer lé déficit nous
en assurons nous en ont fait la
démonstration avec ce chiffre de
croissance 7% qui a généré de cette
recette supplémentaire nous permettant
de réduire les déficits mais il ya un
choix que nous ne faisons pas c'est le
choix de la facilité qui consiste à
augmenter les impôts augmenter les
impôts ça tue la croissance j'ai
souvenir en 2011 madame pécresse était
ministre du budget 15 milliards
d'augmentation d'impôts le gel du barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu la modification
des droits de succession
l'alourdissement de la fiscalité sur les
entreprises nous les impôts nous les
baies sont nous les besson 50 milliards
d'euros la moitié pour les ménages la
moitié par les entreprises et cette
baisse d'impôt nous permet d'avoir le
taux de prélèvements obligatoires le
plus bas depuis 10 ans nous aurons ainsi
effacé les conséquences des deux chocs
fiscaux celui du budget 2011 et celui du
budget 2014 nous allons créer de la
croissance pousser la croissance créer
des recettes nous allons retrouver le
chemin de la consolidation budgétaire de
la maîtrise de la dette comme nous
l'avons fait de 2017 à 2020 car vous
avez oublié une chose monsieur le
sénateur c'est ce gouvernement et lui
seul qui pendant trois ans a tenu les
engagements de la france devant la
commission européenne
80% et un redressement des comptes
publics monsieur ben asher
oui monsieur le président
comme le président de la république vous
même et à l'image de talleyrand vous
traversez les régimes mais contrairement
à talleyrand qui disait quand je me
compare je me console
et quand je me regarde je me désole vous
c'est exactement l'inversé vous consoler
en vous regardant il faut se désole il
faut se désole quand on se compare car
l'allemagne fait mieux que nous mais
pire la grèce rembourse avec deux en
avance la dette qu'elle doit au fmi
quand vous regardez le rapport du fmi il
dit combien la france est une attitude
quand vous regardez le rapport de règles
ses codes il dit combien notre industrie
décroche quand vous regardez les
chiffres de chiffres du commerce
extérieur de la france n'a jamais eu les
pires chiffres alors dans quel état
laissez-vous la france c'est une honte
[Musique]